Got Mr. Walker
All right.
Don't go down.
Well,
I told you what I told you the last time.
Can nobody here you boo,
but they can hear your vote.
All right.
All right. So.
So you got Mr. Walker.
Look,
I was here last night,
and I think I made clear
my thoughts on Mr.
Walker
He I.
I had to acknowledge, and, you know,
some of you,
you know,
everybody here
has pretty good home training, but.
And so,
you know,
you're always reticent
if you don't have something nice to say
about somebody
you don't say.
So I talked about what
a good football player here, but
but I also had that knowledge
that I did not think he had
either the confidence, the character,
the track record of service
that would justify him
representing Georgia
in the United States Senate.
Now,
if
if you had forgotten what I said
the last time, it's okay
because you just have to wait a minute.
He reminds you every time
he opens his mouth
I mean,
every day
he comes up with something
since the last time I was here,
since the last time I was here, Mr.
Walker has been talking about issues
that are of great importance
to the people of Georgia,
like whether it's better to be a vampire
or a werewolf.
This is a debate that I must confess
I once had myself
when I was seven
then I grew up
In case you're wondering, by the way, Mr.
Walker decided
he wanted to be a werewolf,
which is great.
As far as I'm concerned.
He can be anything he wants to be,
except for a United States senator.
Since the last time that
since the last time I was here,
apparently he also claimed
that he used to
let me beat him, that basketball
but then he admitted
then we've never actually met
So I guess this was more of an
imaginary weapon that I laid on him.
Well, listen,
this would be funny.
If he weren't running for Senate.
We all know some folks in our lives
who we don't wish them ill will
they say crazy stuff.
We're all like, well, you know,
Uncle Joe, you know what happened to him?
You know, it's okay.
That they're part of the family,
but you don't give them serious response
to those
when you spend more time
thinking about horror movie fantasies
than you do thinking about the people
you want to represent
that says something
about your priorities.
When again and again you serve up
bald faced lies, just make stuff up
that says something
about the kind of person you are
and the kind of leader
you would be
if you were in the United States Senate.
So, Georgia, look,
I'm not telling you something
you don't know.
You deserve a senator.
You can be proud of
somebody who will talk straight to you,
somebody who will fight for you,
somebody who will garner respect
in Washington,
somebody like Reverend, we're not
who's been doing it responsibly
and conscientiously and effectively.
Not just in the Senate,
not just in the last few years,
but his entire adult life.
So let's bring in now our senior data
reporter, Harry intern.
Good morning to you.
So we have this new
polling out of Georgia,
the Senate runoff there,
just four days out.
What do you have? Yeah.
All right.
So, you know,
let's just start with that
top line that you mentioned.
And we've got Raphael
Warnock with a 52 to 48% lead.
I'll tell you this much.
This race is still within
the margin of error. Right.
That applies to the margin.
The margin of error is a little less
than four points.
The margin here is four points,
but you've got essentially double
that margin
very to understand the margin of error
between the candidates.
So this is still a very narrow advantage,
but it is a larger lead than Warnock had,
of course, in the general election
where he got more votes than Ralph
than Herschel Walker did,
but only by about a point.
This is a four point margin.
Now, let's dig a little bit
deeper, right, to understand
sort of why it is
that Raphael Warnock has the lead.
So which candidate is well qualified,
Raphael Warnock? 52%.
Herschel Walker. 27% has good judgment.
Raphael Warnock, 50%.
Herschel Walker.
33% would effectively represent
and represent the state of Georgia.
Raphael Warnock. 50%.
Herschel Walker. 41%.
So when you look at sort of those
candidate quality issues,
Raphael Warnock
comes out ahead on all of them
and by pretty clear margins.
So this is why Walker is saying
so why is why is Walker staying so close?
You know,
you look at this,
you say Raphael Warnock
should be running away with this. Right?
Look at these kind of qualities.
But let's take a look at what
the biggest factor in your vote
is, right?
So candidate issue positions.
57%.
Candidate character. 42%.
Raphael Warnock is winning the vast
majority of these voters
who say candidate character.
But take a look at this.
57% who say candidate
issue positions
are, in fact,
the biggest factor in your vote.
And take a look at these voters.
These voters
favor
Herschel Walker by a 64% to 35% margin.
So basically the fundamentals
you know
the high inflation
Joe Biden's unpopularity
are keeping this race close
because those voters
they may not love Herschel Walker
but they prefer him to Raphael Warnock
because they just don't like
Raphael Warnock.
It's not necessarily
about loving Herschel Walker.
All right. Harris, thank you very much.
Appreciate it, Harry.
Stick around
a little bit later on the show
because I want you to pay
attention to this ahead.